alors un bon tutoyer pas
et
la vie privée ramzy ça va oui ça va très
bien ben voilà jaser
tu sens que c'est tendu mais ça va c'est
tendu mais ça c'est normal en même temps
réel alors là on va passer à la police
parce qu'on avait
donc la politique en tant que jeunes
issus de la banlieue on faisait pas
beaucoup entendu vous exprimer sur le
problème si vous aviez dû brûler des
voitures vous auriez trouvé quel modèle
de voiture je rêverais celle de ma mère
moi j'aurais brûlé une multiple à moi je
la fais jouer et je pense que même s'ils
auraient
mené les multiples à celle qui ressemble
un dauphin la lazio journée par un
stagiaire c'est à dire d'été
m
je n'ai tourne elle est moche on est
bien dedans
monique et ma femme
était ou non monsieur
[Rires]
vous été déçu que ça présidial pas aux
antilles bah ouais même s'il serait plus
bronzé et du coup en plus présente à
plus présidentiable quasiment regarder
de villepin est super bronze et quelques
jours les beaux seins
moi non mais même si je suis pas
d'accord tout passé mais moi je trouve
que c'est vrai quoi à l'étranger de
villepin c'est la classe et voilà ça va
voir la classe que ce faire le groupe
président français
avec le petit accent français et bien
façon ce sera lui ou sarkozy donc on est
obligé de s'y faire déjà un peu j'aime
bien les le pain zazie non mais je
n'aime pas sarkozy alors
pourquoi parce que ou telle ville pas
bah on est un peu ce qu'on me dit on il
faut qu'on s'y fasse sa part henin était
tellement beau
gagner kouchner coucher un an il avait
conscience que je pense à ce faible ce
qui est c'est le mec reprises mais
pourtant c'est plus élevé mais c'est pas
le plus et lui c'est ça le problème
mais si mon fameux c'est que il faut
absolument pas que tu aies comédiens
côté un mec de coeur serait absolument
pas aimer sarkozy ça ça me gonfle
terribles maux moi je l'aimerais bien
voyez que pour ça comme par exemple toi
les artistes sont à gauche un toit à 80
% parce que c'est pas bien de
d'état droite moi je considère la gauche
et à droite comme papa et maman qui tu
préfères papa ou maman j'aime bien maman
parce que fait des caresses j'ai des
trucs défunt papa il me tape un peu sur
la table pour faire le truc donc tu
préfères qui bat mouvement bas c'est
bien que ce soit un coup papa un court
moment par mois sans être artiste
j'exècre sarkozy
exècre c'est à dire je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de problèmes qu'avec ce qui
s'est passé quoi vis-à-vis de sarkozy
malgré tout pas en face d'eux s'est pas
de l'antisarkozisme qu'on fait moment
essayé de regarder ce qui fait depuis
deux trois ans effectivement ça va pas
dans le sens de l'intégration pour les
jeunes de banlieue ça va plus dans sort
de la répression quoi et bcc et c'est
pas parce que je suis artiste que je dis
ça je vois juste que il ya plein de de
budget qui étaient alloués à d'autres
choses que la répression dans les
banlieues
qui sont plus là et je connais pas mal
la banlieue en fait et je vois que ça
c'est les conditions se détériorent et
que c'est aussi par rapport à une
politique qui est menée et jeu
il se trouve que c'est sarkozy quand
même qu'ils aient la tête de proue de
cette politique est malade et donc le
mieux le mieux c'est surtout pas un seul
flic envolée sais pas ce que je dis mais
je sens que c'est exactement ça non sa
ktm gamine que tu as du mal à lui
envoyer prendre une baguette de pain
comme moi dans des endroits où j'ai
habité tu dis elle va traverser la place
s'il sait pas si elle va revenir je dis
que c'est pas tout rien par exemple je
dis non ce ne sont pas tout répressif ou
tout juste sympa keufs sympa donc rien
j'ai aucun problème
par exemple moi c'est pour ça que je dis
je le répète par exemple de
responsabiliser les parents pour qu'ils
s'occupent de leurs enfants je pense pas
que ça soit fasciste c'est comme ça la
loi le dit comme ça les parents sont
propriétaires corps et âme de leurs
enfants c'est à dire si un pitbull
bouffe la gueule d'une petite fille on
va condamner le propriétaire des bills
mais jean-marie excuse moi ça c'est tout
à fait logique tout le monde le comprend
non atteint
non je m'arriver à moi mais moi je suis
en pourparlers avec une telle heure et
j'entends les mots comme police puis de
bull shit et il est là le problème c'est
quoi ce bordel pour 100 actions
positives et si on a trois mauvaises
c'est l'e3 sur lesquels on veut mettre
le premier j'ai entendu tu allais il y
avait il y avait des associations dans
les banlieues qui étaient subventionnés
qui envoyait les jeunes en vacances ou
qui les envoyer dans des familles
d'accueil les budgets on saute les les
budgets ont sauté ces gamins là qu'est
ce qu'ils font et mercredi après midi
ils galèrent dans les halls qu'est ce
qu'on vient de leur interdire de les
orienter l'ohl donc où il est leur
espace de liberté ster que on leur
enlève
les petits et les petits cadeaux les
petits bonbons et ensuite on leur enlève
les endroits où ils peuvent au moins se
voir discuter quoi juste un espace
privilégié pour
bien évidemment des problèmes dans les
halls il ya des gens qui arrivent pas à
dormir parce que les gamins ils parlent
dans les eaux jusqu'à minuit 1h du mat
mais c'est pas la majorité des rôles de
banlieue sauf que c'est ce que c'est le
discours de sarkozy ça veut dire tous
les gamins maintenant sont dans les
halls et font du bruit les gens
responsables n'arrive pas à dormir donc
interdisons les halls aux jeunes les
deux nous donnant du travail enfin
prenons les cv acceptons les donnons
leur du travail égal est rompue dans les
halls parce qu'il faut se lever le
lendemain matin voilà
c'est comme ça
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu que ce que
vous dites j'irais comme président un
petit truc parce que je vais je risque
de passer pour le facho tiers non je te
connais tu ne l'est pas et donc dans ma
rue moi et je ne sais pas si vous le
faites dans votre rue mais moi dans ma
rue il n'ya pas un mec qui traînent par
terre que je ne vais pas voir et qui je
demande qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
lui et de quoi il a besoin on sait bien
ce que les
gens mariés s'étaient chacun d'entre
nous devraient faire mais seulement
quand un pays tout entier à t'occuper
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de tous et
non ce n'est pas plus difficile mais on
est amis vachement de côté c'est à dire
ça fait quand même c'est le problème il
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui ça fait des
années que c'est comme ça j'ai déjà
sauté avant l'heure que owen dans les
rangs des quelques ententes ya pas eu d
il ya eu des émeutes ces deux modes qui
sont pas l'équivalent de ça et
mitterrand est venu semble dans les
cités il avait fait un voyage c'est
parce que la cité des 4000 à la
courneuve à la courneuve il est allé et
il a dit ouais ça ça on va raser ça on
va raser ça on va raser ça va changer il
y avait les caméras c'était il ya vingt
ans et elles sont restées et je pense
que l'effet zidane a fait que tout ça ça
a pu et d'angré n'est encore un petit
peu parce qu'en 90 temps idéal c'est bon
on marque des buts donc c'est génial
zidane président donc les arabes ça va
tout va bien les mecs de cités ça va il
s'en sortent et en fait ça a permis mais
sinon les émeutes auraient dû exploser
il ya encore il ya six ans a normalement
et il ya autre chose que ce que j'ai
entendu que il ya des jeunes qui ont le
choix entre vendre du shit ou bien aller
travailler et oyonnax qui préfèrent
aller vendre du shit et alors ça
vraiment non ç'a vraiment sérieux c'est
un vrai choix leur nombre à un moment
c'est un vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est pas vrai j'étais un mec ou deux
qui vont vendus soit mais c'est pas
genre 55 ans mia moment bassin mais la
question est posée qu'à un moment donné
le jeune qui est dans deux eaux va
effectivement lui faire cette
proposition et si jamais ils l'acceptent
et ben il va après avoir du mal à aller
gratter mais la première proposition
jean-marie la première proposition
monsieur mateu coupé elle vient quand
même du jeune qui envoie son cv et qu'on
lui dit non donc la proposition après du
dealer de shit elle vient après et je
veux finir sur la dernière chance entre
cette image nous regarder la meilleure
solution est ce qu'il faut faire à
partir de maintenant c'est faut qu'on
aille voter il faut qu'on aille tous
voté et que ça sera le meilleur moyen
pour avoir des gens qui nous
représenteront et de se faire écouter il
faut aller voter
amélie
on est d'accord si on peut faire quelque
chose ici pour que les jeunes s'inscrit
pour 2007 moi je pense que
chacun d'entre nous devraient essayer de
s'occuper de son prochain et si il y en
a seulement deux ou trois par rue eh ben
on règle vraiment beaucoup de problème
donc que tu t'inquiètes de ton voisin eh
ben tu fais tout simplement pas quinze
mille morts de la solitude pas morts de
la canicule on sait cours et sont pas
morts de la canicule les vieux sont hors
de la solitude parce que leurs voisins
de palier ne s'occupait pas de la
vieille personne qui était à côté d'eux
bien évidemment nous sommes évidemment
mais
marie pense que si tu voyais des gens
qui sont vraiment détruit en bas de chez
toi tu méprises ans avec comme sarkozy
par exemple parce que c'est c'est il est
le messie parce que six mètres en
extérieur il paraît simple et schmoll du
ou n'importe quoi vous vous gueulez pris
quelqu'un qui
regarde se fait engueuler sur un mec
qu'on gueule sur un mec qui donc a coupé
les budgets pour aider tous les
problèmes de quartier comme eric en a
parlé de la volonté mais surtout je
laissais le même mec qui fait qui fait
des lois pour pour alléger l'impôt sur
la grosse fortune est-ce que des
politiciens l'impôt sur les grosses
fortunes d'alternance en voisin pas
connu mais très bien mais
chez nous sur ce qui se passe chez nous
et autres chaussures les parents est à
blâmer des parents nos excuses moitié
mais de blâmer les parents et leur dire
ce sont les parents qui sont
responsables je trouve ça scandaleux et
ben sultan
maman qui a justement qu'à 80 ans si
j'étais encore au quartier aujourd'hui
c'est pas elle qui me bloquerait
pourtant située à elle c'est même le
mercato parle quasiment pas assisté à la
87e tu vois pas en quoi elle va
m'empêcher de me laissera pas sortir
deux heures parce que je suis pas de la
génération juste aujourd'hui et je suis
sûr que je suis sorti du quartier mais
tu vas dans les quartiers et les
corrigera 6 heures l'après-midi des
ballons on se dit que même si les
parents ont eux mêmes été abandonnés par
leurs parents le problème quand même
vient de la racine dans blender
le prennent bien de ces mecs qu'on
construit ces espèces d'immondices
d'horreur total sur
les gradins monde et là ils sont restés
des parents si le problème c'est que
simplement quant à d espèce de truc qui
se dégradent un seul geste on les
adresse ya pas de boulot et 55 ans sont
classés pas les parents qu'on est déçu
mais il ya cette aide reste là il est là
aussi le problème allons tous voter
nommé par côte et votre discours il est
il et il englobe absolument tout alors
que ça n'est pas vrai qu'est ce qui
n'est pas vrai c'est à dire qu'il ya une
partie comme par exemple en corse si tu
me dis que tous les corps sont des
[ __ ] non mais par contre il ya des
tueurs qui ne veulent que tu es qui sont
d entre eux c'est toute la corne à
savoir
si ces
salaires de shit par exemple et ils font
pas tous vendeurs de ramsey y en a
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
lean a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux